[Music]
so as soon as the ancient Egyptians
start to be buried with things in their
tombs like 5000 BCE
essentially tomb robbing begins almost
immediately and as an archaeologist you
just need to assume that the tomb that
you're Excavating has been robbed before
you got there because it happened so
utterly frequently
and the Egyptians thought that it was
really important to include objects in
your tomb I mean the afterlife was
considered like life on Earth but
without any problems so you still needed
stuff
tombs essentially have two different
types of generic objects within them you
have objects that help you get into the
Afterlife things with magical spells on
them like the Book of the Dead or your
scarabs or you have objects that you're
going to use in the afterlife once
you're already there things like food
and clothing and furniture you have
things like your perishable Goods so
they're actually buried with real food
and real flowers now once those are
underground you're probably not going to
want to reuse them but there's a lot of
durable goods too things like furniture
and linen that even if you get some dirt
on them you can still reuse them and the
most valuable objects are going to be
your metal and your semi-precious Stone
[Music]
obviously if they thought there were
precious metals that would go first so
gold or bronze would be among the things
they would be first looking for but they
would know based on the social level of
the Tomb they were going to rob what the
likelihood would be
[Music]
all of these objects that people had an
innate and just put them in the ground
you're essentially like taking wealth
out of society just to bury it but at
the same time tomb robbing was a highly
immoral and unethical act most people
did not do this because when you steal
things from a tomb you are also harming
the afterlife for the person in the Tomb
too and most people took this very very
very seriously
[Music]
would have been an age or crime in
ancient Egypt clearly there were severe
Corporal punishments for Tomb robbers
but one of the worst things is the
curses
because not only would you as the tomb
robber suffer but the curses would damn
oftentimes your wife and your children
sometimes even your grandchildren so yes
it was a grave crime to rub a tomb in
ancient Egypt however that did not stop
people The Economic Consequences of that
level of real organized crime which is
what happened in the end of the New
Kingdom we actually see a lot of
material that was stolen out of these
tombs surface in the Royal burials at
Tanis in the 21st and 22nd dynasties and
almost certainly we see the what had
been earlier stuff that's been melted
down
and reformed into new things as well
so you might ask who the tomb robbers
are they are not who you think
from most of our evidence we know that
the majority of Tomb robbers were
actually middle and upper class people
they're not starving but they are the
people with the opportunity and they're
the people with the means sometimes they
have inside knowledge occasionally they
are the same priests that supposedly
buried the dead and then you know to
skim some things off the top sometimes
you have Sailors or craftsmen or Cory
men or just your officials that found
the record in the back of the palace or
found the record in the back of the
archives as to where a tomb was they are
the people with the means to do it once
you take the items out of the Tomb you
need to fence them right you need to
actually turn them over so they have
marketplaces in Egypt where you can go
and trade goods if you go up to the you
know the marketplace 100 miles from your
house where nobody recognizes you you
might be able to trade some Goods there
especially things like linen or
furniture that is unidentifiable if you
have things like metal you can also melt
them down and turn them into scrap
that's where you need a system of
Craftsmen to help you out you end up
expanding your criminal Network to get
specific Craftsmen to maybe washing a
particular item or take a name off an
object or resell it or reuse it on that
particular level to kind of like
um launder your theft in some ways
a lot of tombs especially with above
ground structures or pyramids on top
essentially are giant x marks the spot
on where stuff actually is and so tomb
robbing happens pretty quickly after
somebody dies it can happen within hours
days weeks years months uh and then
several several years later too in
addition to that tombs aren't just
robbed once tombs are robbed multiple
times through their history it's more
like a small drip of items coming out of
the Tomb over years and years to come
there are times in history when tomb
robbing is more common specifically
during the intermediate periods times of
War also times when the government is
not centralized because that's when
tombs are not protected as well and when
tombs are more of an opportunity for
wealth for officials that's the time
when officials end up Gathering Together
loads of workmen to actively Rob the
tomb so that they can earn the money for
their pause at that point
intermediate periods for ancient Egypt
are sort of a convenient way for us to
distinguish between times when there
were very strong dynasties of Kings on
the throne where centralized Authority
was not questioned and we can talk about
a predictable succession from King to
King then there are periods where for a
variety of different reasons
um that strong centralized autocracy
weakens and you have a movement of power
into Regional areas and that's what
intermediate periods really represent if
we look at the
there were upside down
the poor have become rich and everybody
you know is is everything's wrong those
texts are written by the elite
so it depends his point of view
from the point of view of the non-elite
what we find is oftentimes there was a
how shall I put it a redistribution of
wealth that perhaps was not as it didn't
seem as bad to those who are benefiting
from it than others
so there are multiple ways to protect
your tomb and the primary way to protect
a tomb is to have guards in a cemetery
so these guards are really the most
effective when the government is
centralized and strong when they're paid
and when the corruption of local
officials is low and we actually have a
number of Trials of Tomb robbers
specifically in the New Kingdom who are
arrested for robbing the tombs they're
put on trial they're actually publicly
killed and impaled on stakes in the city
their death was a determined for a
possible future tomb Robert and yet it
was still so profitable that you in fact
do still have tomb robbing
[Music]
thank you